here in germany the number of
coronavirus infections has soared in
recent days
the country's leading public health
institute is warning
that people are letting down their guard
and not observing social distancing
measures
ironic then that berlin is set to see
its biggest demonstration
against coronavirus restrictions
thousands of people are gathered
in the germans capital central
tiergarten park for a mass
rally demanding an end to all
virus-related restrictions
conspiracy theorists anti-vaxxers and
right-wing extremists from across the
country
are among those attending it comes as
germany braces for a potential second
wave
of the corona violence
dw political correspondent leonie von
hammerstein
is at the protest and she joins me now
leone welcome
what's happening where you are
well i'm standing here behind me tens of
thousands that's at least 15 000 people
have gathered you described it for they
call it a day of freedom the end of the
pandemic
they are celebrating the end of the
coronavirus pandemic as
authorities are warning of a new surgeon
of infections
and right on the other side you can see
the counter protesters
that have also gathered here the
apparent difference as you can
see counter protesters are wearing the
face masks are keeping the social
distance
whereas the protesters here at this
match are not um almost none of them are
wearing face masks and
and they've been shouting and the
pandemic has never happened
uh the pandemic gap is knee and there
was an interesting stand up between
counter protesters and protesters both
shouting at each other's
nazis raus nazis get out of here because
the people who are attending this match
um are expressing their discontent their
distrust with the government's measures
and and are calling those that are
listening to the government's um
lockdown measures the coronavirus
restrictions and comparing them
to nasa to the people who followed the
ns regime in the 30s
and so this is an interesting conflict
going on right behind me
yeah and an interesting uh contrast
between you wearing the mask and all
those people behind you
obviously flagrantly not doing so i'm
really curious about those protesters
taking part in the demonstration today
could you tell us a little bit more
about who they are
[Applause]
exactly i talked to many of the
protesters here and there's really a
wide variety of people who've come here
from all over germany
transported let's start with i talked to
a bus
um bus driver from croatia who is driven
protesters from the south of germany up
to the north he is protesting the
coronavius restriction that
that have impacted the tourism industry
then i talked to somebody or
better a protester shouted in my face
and we've seen that a lot a lot of
verbal abuse and attacks
and up until uh physical physical people
are not keeping their socialism also to
us as oppressed
um as the press and who believes in
conspiracy theory he believes that
bill gates is a very common conspiracy
theory that bill gates is behind the
corona virus
and wants to vaccinate forcefully
vaccinate everybody and the german
government is helping him to do that
so we see a wide variety of people who
are concerned about their
their parents and who are concerned
about
the restrictions in place because their
parents are lonely up until
right wing and far right writing extreme
magazines and grooves who are under
observation by the authority i saw
someone from the compact magazine who's
been
under observation by the authorities for
its xenophobic and revisionist
messages so you can see this really
all sorts of people attending this rally
and
definitely what we can say to sum up is
they don't trust the government they
don't trust the government measures and
they don't trust the media and they
don't trust the media's challenges
thank you for that and stay safe of
course
let's take a look at uh some of the
other coronavirus related developments
the number of deaths in mexico has
surged past 46 000
it's now poised to overtake britain as
the country with the third highest death
toll behind brazil in the u.s
british prime minister boris johnson
says he's putting on the brakes
easing lockdown measures and will be
instead
imposing new restrictions that's after a
new spike in coronavirus infections
in the uk and in japan the region of
okinawa has declared a state of
emergency
people have been asked to stay home for
two weeks as the popular tourist
destination
sees a surge in new cases
you